[Music]
welcome to the first in a new series of
III events where we'll be uncovering the
beef philosophical issues behind the
everyday news headlines in search of new
ways of thinking that might enable us to
create a better world now during the
pandemic the world has become transfixed
with a number of virus deaths these
figures are not only a recognition of
the personal tragedy involved there
they've also been central to our
understanding of the epidemic and to
help governments determine their
response but can we be confident of the
numbers and what do they tell us about
how we should act with me an influential
panel you're ideally placed to answer
this question mark xi is a biophysicist
a professor at Stanford University
who won the Nobel Prize in 2013 Johnson
is an epidemiologist specializing in
infectious disease and professor at
University College London and the former
adviser to governments Toby Young
associate editor of the right-leaning
political magazine The Spectator and
he's recently launched a website titled
lockdown skeptics and David Alexander
professor of risk and disaster reduction
at UCL and also a former adviser to
government now if we're going to
understand the numbers let's begin with
the question of how we in fact determine
the cause of death and whether we can do
so with any clarity now medics have to
make this decision whenever they're
completing a death certificate how do
they determine the cause of death and is
this the same across the world
well the registration of death is done
through our office for national
statistics and it's a complex process in
that a doctor when they fill in a
certificate in this country will write
it down the number the factors that have
may have contributed that death
including what is described as the
underlying cause of death
so the most robust figures on deaths
will come from what is registered with
Office of National Statistics and we get
those figures in detail every week
there's a distinction between the
immediate cause of death and an
underlying cause of death so somebody
when the doctor will fill in the
conditions that may have contributed to
the death which could include
coronavirus but it also might may
include other conditions for example
having had a former stroke or having had
a heart attack ultimately for example if
someone the given example if somebody
had terminal cancer they might
eventually die from pneumonia but the
underlying cause of death would be
regarded as their cancer what what OH&S
is doing that in the counties as giving
numbers where coronavirus occurs in
either part of the destitute because I
understand it and that's what the ONS
counts are currently coming from and in
terms of the underlying I mean is this
is it always apparent what the
underlying cause is and would it include
causes like poverty or poor diet so
those conditions we know though
essentially that there are many
conditions related to poverty and to
socioeconomic determines which increase
our risk of of dying but the actual
cause of death would be ascribed to the
clinical condition which resulted in
that death so do you think the number of
polling deaths tells us whether they
have died from perfect in order to do
that one would have to look at not more
detail at the detail of what was written
by the doctor on the on the death
certificate and I mean in some sense is
also there are also going to be deaths
which won't be ascribed to Kovac which
may have in which code would may have
played a part if that person wasn't
tested and then of course so the
indirect deaths will come on to that
later where there are people who have
for example and developed the symptoms
of a heart attack they may decide for
example whether the changes in the
health system that they don't they don't
go into hospital when they might have
done before again
difficult to know to what extent that
death may or may not occurred if the
health system had been different and to
do that we have to look at excess
mortality so to what extent can we trust
the number of Cobie deaths I mean it
sounds like there's a lot of
decision-making there in determining
whether a death is the result of coded
or not well I think we can certainly
ascribe very large numbers of cases of
people who have come into hospital being
diagnosed with Kovach have all the
symptoms of courage and subsequently die
and we can be clear that many of those
Hospital deaths will be ascribed to Kobe
the actual division of all those
different groups I've described is
something that we will have to be
looking at in much more forensic detail
in the coming months and years but there
is no doubt that we have seen an
enormous number of deaths in this
country related to kovin it's then
difficult again to make meaningful
comparisons between different countries
in any exact terms both because of the
stage of the epidemic and also
differences in ways in the ways that
countries actually record their best so
Michael do you think that we can trust
the number of deaths that we see from
different countries and do you think
they're comparable we have not been the
best source of numbers at least for all
of Europe is a website called euro mama
it covers about 300 million people in
Europe and so far the excess death in
the last eight or nine weeks has been
about a hundred and forty thousand
people which is a significant number
it's about a little bit less than three
weeks of normal death so you know that's
a large number it's not maybe it's maybe
20% larger than of two epidemic in 1718
but it's definitely a significant number
now we don't even know whether that's
mostly today or mostly I mean we the
number one's been broken out by country
but at least the total there seem to be
sensible and you saying the total error
is only 20% more than seasonal flu
deaths in 1718 it's something like that
would you accept that David I think
that's probably true serious pirate
box here but them in disasters death is
an absolute matter but counting deaths
is a very relative business and in mass
casualty disasters is pretty common
indeed is they're all not the exception
to have trouble getting the numbers if
we look back to the haiti earthquake of
2010 we have no idea how how many people
died if we look at the fruit pandemic
1918 1920 you have absolutely no idea
how many deaths they were because in
most cases they were not counted at all
well at least we are trying to account
now although I'm sure it will be very
difficult to get any kind of reliable
and reasonably figure with background
mortality didn't take into account one
of the obvious issues here is there are
huge variation so they're not between
countries with different deaths per
million by not just one order of
magnitude but two orders of magnitude
difference is this really because of the
way that governments are responding or
is it something to do with the way the
numbers are being calculated I think
it's because you have a disease that
spreads exponentially if it doesn't
spread exponentially you don't have so
many cases if it does then you have a
large proportion of cases as well as
potentially a large number of cases I
think this is a function of how the
disease spreads so so you think that the
difference is the huge differences we
see between populations is largely to do
with the speed of the spread in the
different countries yes and in fact I
don't think it necessarily reflects very
particularly on the quality of
management at least not after the early
stages it probably does reflect on the
quality of management in the initial
stages where there is some prospect of
stopping the exponential spread of the
disease and if that is not done then the
disease simply rips away but are you
suggesting that in a lot of cases that's
not the case and the the actual response
doesn't make that much difference I
think after a certain amount of time
wrote the response does make a
difference
physical distancing makes it
or distance but once you've got the
disease and once it is disseminated
among the public then it's very much
there and it's very easy for the numbers
to mount up what we've seen in the
lesson we've learnt at least I hope
we've learnt it is that firm only action
of an appropriate kind in testing
tracing and preventing and so on and
isolating is capable of stopping huge
prizes in the number of cases in
particular places should also bear in
mind that of course the number in a
particular country which is simply
administrative unit is not likely to be
uniform around the country so then we
have to ask for a way numbers are in a
particular place it may be population
density may be the way in which people
behave on the spread of the disease
follows but no it's certainly not
uniform even in some in a fairly small
country like a little more Denmark so
Michael what do you make of all of that
I think that the mean Europe you know a
lot of countries have been and
substantial numbers of deaths again it's
it's it's horrible to count deaths like
this but it's in some ways are a proxy
for how many people are infected those
four cases are not really very valuable
and you actually look at the numbers you
find that in Europe the the places where
the gain where where I'm making a
mistake I was warned not to make it by
taking a country as uniform but it seems
that most countries sort of stopped when
they have about between a half and one
person per thousand who has died
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a I dot TV
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas